the bill takes more than 80 different
revenue streams that go to schools and
puts them all
into one giant pot of school money that
means it does away with programs like
zoom schools and victory schools those
are programs that give extra money to
schools with high numbers of
english language learners or students on
free and reduced
lunches instead all the money from the
new giant pot will be given to schools
based on what are called
weights for the students those weights
will be higher for students with special
needs
that are at risk or that are english
language learners
and the school will get more money the
nevada state education association
voiced concerns during the first hearing
this week
saying they want to keep those programs
like zoom and victory schools
so let's talk about gathering up all
that money into one pot
for now governor steve sisilak wants to
only do that with the money from the
state
money from local sources like property
taxes would
not go into that pot for a few years
about
70 percent of the money that goes to
schools now is from
local sources the bill is exempt so
lawmakers have three weeks to figure out
all of that there has also not been any
new money
assigned to education yet this session